[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club ladies they will
have open challenges with international
master Tyler Cervantes welcome to the
show for the first time welcome
everybody who's watching I'm really
excited to be here it's my first time
with this lady's night stream and just
as a reminder and I reminder you can
challenge us um the description below
and we also have two classes later today
at 6:00 and 7:00 p.m. with international
master doors of the rock Shani here at
the Chess Club so hopefully you can come
and enjoy but yeah we're going to play
some games today yeah so you're welcome
to challenge us only chess and we're
looking for challenges with five minutes
or three to blitz so let's start with
the first one that I saw I guess
let's see oh I have another faces before
but it could be dangerous
maybe I don't know just gonna make
natural mousse and see what happens
well then get our pieces out with
threads like here the e4 pawn then
that's good now just imagine that move
but alright let's just keep developing
our pieces since there's no other way
around it
our position looks fine so far I can't
promise anything
and I'm guessing we'll be joined by my
mom right now
people more experienced than me here
yeah I mean everything is going well so
far and hopefully it stays that way
okay so
and then I donate three is not doing any
oops then I donate three is not doing
anything so if it goes to c4
we might have some b5 some tricks
huh would you look at that they weren't
watching the stream website do you think
people would do that
what's the stream to know my thoughts
and then make moves I'm not missing
anything we should be like it is i
working on starting a new twitch channel
and us test i was playing some games
before starting to stream and i couldn't
even have a good test because i kept
loosing every game i was nervous
and there were like no people watching
me it was just a test
not even a stream hmm but everything is
going well so far
and this night is strapped to so it
could be two pieces up
make a move he's like you know when when
I was playing in a tournament one time
chica open my opponent was in a similar
situation where they couldn't they
couldn't come up with a good with a good
move so they just spent 40 minutes
looking at the board and I was just
walking around my some some of the
players walking near me we're
congratulating me like yeah that was a
pretty good move and my opponent didn't
do anything for for like 40 minutes
this I don't mind maybe I'll lose the e5
but then I go Bishop d6 and this one
might be falling yeah alright so that
was that was nice
okay let's let's see this one I like the
name okay are done could them I don't
know
[Laughter]
London do you like them
no no only one I get to play it and what
you mean us that's why yeah you like
that's fine
did you need to like her that's black
now I don't like it at all at all cuz
people use it against me but I'm playing
it now okay so you have you don't have
much pain no no
ah that's a unusual move I should be
doing about it
not steak usually we haven't finished
all of your development and if you
already moved upon once and I are
opening your Center then some problems
might come around
if he takes the floor okay here and play
but if she takes it further I would have
taken with the Queen probably and now we
have takes and if context back bishop ah
once again Bishop c3 looking at the king
yeah we have the very we have very good
yeah we have very good tactics book here
that you might want to check out so you
don't fall for tricks like this just so
he has nothing
h5 hmm I guess now I'm just having some
fun with the position hopefully that
won't come back to betray me I think
game should be over somewhat soon pins
pins are important don't get their get
into bad things like this one yeah I
just had a student who I was teaching
about pins and so I reminded me of this
and you can go check out the famous
what's it called opera game by Murphy do
you know what it's called yeah it's my
part of the whole theater is boring but
streams are not chess club students or
not so here we are and it doesn't matter
I [ __ ] my king because it's still
safe and I'm threatening
we'll just have to wait and see and I
have anyone wasted well I know I wasted
a minute then I was doing good so far
how many pieces are we
hmmm so much should I do
he's just gonna take all my pieces in
five minutes
I think I'm gonna pick even more pieces
now because you do them for the
principles I know you're out there
you're watching you play d4 that wasn't
necessary
oh one more little place in my life you
feel confident about this game well you
know it's - right right right moment to
resign okay let's try this one abso 7d
for once again and see you said you
liked London opening you did not anymore
not anymore
very cool sister but after my
demonstration do you like black now no I
said it was the probably the best game
of my life and you just reject it like
that
well if if it's not broken and I don't
need to fix it so I'm gonna play the
same thing I played last game and see
how it goes
I'll play b6 Bishop d7 if everything
goes according to normal
we should should
Mattia later on we'll be Knight d7
rookie a then I'm try to play e5 but
we'll see maybe I'll change my mind in
the meantime
it's a lot of fun for you right now well
my aunt's chest I'll enjoy it so nice I
don't lose weight it's not for certain
here
and maybe I'm just playing really fast
or my opponents are taking a long time
but it's okay I I tend to spend more
time than I should on regular games so
can't judge her for that
we have some expectations here only just
looking at the game okay
so similar idea to to our previous game
here he played oops play before so I'm
going to take maybe I could do after
Knight takes something like Knight takes
d4 maybe I'm just getting too too into
it
hmm not take with the phone first and
after context maybe 94 because we have a
discovery with the bishop see what I
mean it was silly for 94
hopefully it works Oh Oh apparently we
have a four versus three score against
this player so we have played him before
or her what it is but I'm glad we're up
I don't know who I allowed those other
three points to sleep when I have to
talk to them later but we're doing good
so far I think
all right so oops I think this is fine I
don't think I'm missing anything
oh it's like 17
yeah we have a lot of challenges so I'm
in the chat and there's no rating
restrictions right now just challenge us
with either a blitz 500 or 3/2
like we are
it's gonna be a lot of chest and you can
handle all of these things well I'm
gonna have to make you play a game at
some point yeah don't you want to so I
guess our positions pretty good right
now once again a pin I think that move
be three maybe wasn't so great I don't
know if they wanted to play before and
instead dropped upon could be a
possibility but okay I guess that's not
good
this will take and after Knight takes
back Bishop takes anyone about it it's
true beginning that way are even better
I was gonna say would be giving away our
fan shadow Bishop but you know it's not
exchanged for nothing so so clean our
mission when when looks prettier maybe I
couldn't have the threat of taking here
maybe I can just move my coming away
trade pieces since were one piece up
this is going well so far look at my
charm
have 19 challenges now son I'll be 20
I'm pretty excited to play all of you
and if not the most of you so let's just
no no fun for you they have 30 seconds
which I'm pretty sure I won't be able to
screw up the huge difference the whole
27 seconds - you don't think so no no
see some time after wonders before not
my best moments but today I think I'm
good for now
sorry aren't you doing your on the job
don't mess around okay so yeah we won
here yep okay now that's up to you
there we go yes some white pieces love
that supposed to do each other like the
play please play okay should I try some
different openings later on like so
should I like be all over the place or
should I focus on winning it's totally
up to you but probably focus on the
winning I want straight go I don't wanna
make a mess yeah
oh if he was in the shot then maybe he's
looking here while we're playing trying
to trying to steal my ideas and use them
against me can't allow something like
that but I'm gonna keep commenting this
is I don't know much about the line to
be honest but this is all normal I
believe
maybe some I was gonna say b5 we shall
be to a six of singles I guess before
and still takes a three said iPhone it's
not hanging could be forgotten but it
won't be
don't want you to take my bishop and I
could play rook c8 and castle sure or
maybe if I feel mood to risk everything
I'll cuss alone but since we are here I
think I'm just gonna play rock c1 for
now since you have both of your most
important pieces here sorry no no no
five and then Bishop a5 hopefully don't
leave the stream keep watching and
that's that's how you win so let's go
Bishop a5 our thread don't tell him is
my 9 that is the hanim Bishop v6 which I
believe is powerful so maybe he won't
see it did you look at that
my psychic abilities I'm working today
hmm
now we are winning at least in exchange
I have some ideas of like Bishop h6 or
real takes c6 Bishop I see me just
resign didn't even bother for and oh
alright no is there anybody else that I
should go hey who's in the shot just
let's see avoid the rush that sounds
nice
crosses good game thank you yeah good
game I hope you enjoyed our something
yeah let's go
so you can go out on Lee chest and find
a new challenge LM st. Louis chess club
and we're at sixteen challenges right
now mm-hmm
and just click challenge and hopefully
we'll get to you here ya go to the
description of this video and challenges
so you get a chance to be on YouTube
life
I don't know how exciting it is to play
me I hope you you'll have a fun time
so if texts we take I don't know if that
was the best idea oh wait maybe I have
some chances here once again DeLong I
don't know might help us mm-hmm let's go
back
always retreat
I'm gonna go away for one of my favorite
moves to make do you play efore or Steve
for me for you far I still haven't
gotten there
naturally I did that I played efore
before I play d4 mm-hmm that was a long
time ago
Mike around five years ago such a long
time ago yeah really I was younger look
at me I'm wearing makeup to go around my
my under eyes all right
so queen G for the idea is to take you
for and also h6 and if the Queen moves
away that maybe we don't take dc5 that
is very interesting and then this year
greetings from hey oh yeah and he says
miss you're going down so accept a
challenge from him I'm sorry after this
one yeah do you think we could do like
two two games at the same time I know me
I'm gonna make Ojai almost there's no
need for my bed no wasn't happening
very good
[Music]
take and even though make our pawn
structure look a little bit earlier oh
this is so for him and huh didn't even
take I was gonna say if he takes back I
was gonna play with the one and not
allow the night to come out but you know
since we're here no no what I'm not even
gonna take you up on you didn't take
care if he wants yeah
go after something bigger and I have the
bishop pair wishes I've entered Xin open
positions like this one we have talked
about this on the lady's class right I
believe so the bishops if not then if
you're a lady and you don't know about
this come to our class yeah
even if you live out of sounds and then
I'm really far from San Luis come to our
class yeah
so in 95 hmm not should I do
I want to give up my wish
what do you think should I take care
should I move away you're asking me all
right no no move away
I have some comments when people from
all over the world here from Poland from
London says hello and hello everyone I
appreciate every single one of you and
if you speak Spanish you're gonna do
that in shot too
cuz I'll understand it she will
understand it and I will attempt to read
it but yeah that would be nice
nobody fun oh my gosh we're not gonna do
that so I could take and when the route
takes which I believe will happen I
could play a rookie one and play for the
trick of Queen takes c3 so I don't know
if I should do that or not I don't wanna
I'm not going to do that just in case
you see sir I also don't want to have an
opposite colored bishop in-game or you
may know game in this case so I won't do
that for now
but who knows
it's still waiting for other huh see
this is hard
she's one of the ladies that attends
ladies night saw do you say no super
she's huh yes yes hi
she should definitely be here yeah what
are you doing you should be here right
now participate in the check here come
to the class
yeah I'm sure some of them will maybe be
in the class later you know first time I
had to teach late this night which was a
little bit a little bit over a year ago
actually maybe two years I was really
excited about it and I told to my some
of my male friends you know what dress
up and I want you to come see my class
will be very nice and I've gotten
requests for males had the chest go up
to during the class and I always have to
say you know I like chess so I'll let
you come in but this is ladies night so
and I'm trying to avoid the rush my
opponent is getting into the rush oh I
miss something not that big of a deal so
don't worry about it um should I is
there something better
let's go here first
the ideas of Bishop takes we can say it
on c8 just don't tell anybody
don't tell him maybe he's watching maybe
he's not then he's watching this like oh
that's nice I think we can take care now
and we should take stick sticks yeah
I'll just never work
we take c5 then something takes on e5
I'm guessing the bishop since we're
talking the Rogan also Bishop h7 so know
that's happening so that's the rook and
Bishop e7 I don't know how you're going
to be able to cope with that with so
little time
uh-huh so if then that's actually a nice
move but I think I can just go here and
not even Bishop is I mean just we should
be faster my bishop stays on the day I'm
gonna should I take oh damn that was a
nice move hi mister Oh No okay so we can
play of three I think or know of three
then Bishop takes that's not good for us
we could play Queen f3 or queen of five
and I think that should be good
I just need to be fast right now so
Bishop
whatever let's just go here I miss a
move on oh I was so complacent about my
position man you know you don't always
miss stuff now we're fine everything's
fine how I just strayed off everything
when this this is a winning game I
believe
just remove the check come back cover
the square take care take this phone yep
you didn't operate the right dangerous
that was cool right
so we have so um it was Ayman Ivanoff
28 2007 this one yep okay but there was
this other guy right who said who said I
was going down yeah this is him
oh this is him yeah good you'll see Oh
got a little trash-talking coin that's
good you lazy backfire
some neither fool I forgot about this
like oops okay you wanna hear some of my
attempted Spanish all right go for it
hold on something real easy something
really like Cola yeah apart you got that
fungi got that okay so I don't know what
to do make normal moves I work out I
don't know what I'm doing but you know
as long as I make normal moose things
should be okay
although this is an either orphan it can
get very dangerous at any point
wait I just noticed something just like
a no time game stating that I put a time
on there huh
but I mean he's playing fast so I hope I
can finish him off quickly they will
never know for now at least
okay so I'll just continue with like
rook c8 b5 and make some normal a
Sicilian stuff that moves I think is
good or should I try to fight for
something let's just make one quick
check maybe I should have saved it for
later but you know maybe I'm trying to
be five now like energy for sorry and
yeah maybe we can all go Knights
Knight g4 f5 bishop yeah whatever
hopefully it works then I thread this
night of to and 93 so we'll see f5 is a
possibility but maybe we shop c4 and
after b3 you're watching this aren't you
alright so but I mean I could also come
back which is a legitimate option
I'll just retreat if nightly five-night
of two anyway and if kim ji-won they'll
be a tree oh don't we do this now I
believe we can I hope he plays King G
can't can you answer but not for the
Queen but for some other stuff no I
think we're fine now queen is not
getting trapped or at least that's what
I believe
should I repeat no I'm not Ravi 800 my
god if I play rook e8 could lose my
claim
mainly seven
our queen is c5 Quincy five looks nice
is there something going on in the chat
yeah it's just like I said I was gonna
attempt my Spanish but you know what
they're not going to it'll be the
funniest joke of the day
mhm some of it is like okay that's clear
what's what's being said and then I'm
just like hmm
I hope my clean is not getting trucked
so let's see if Quincy for know know
what we should do like maybe going with
five and night
maybe I just made a little mistake
so
let's see Queen B flat C 3 oh hello
we have somebody joining us know what
know that joining me when I'm struggling
oh no wait so 22 22 minutes left in the
whole stinger B 5
[Music]
what should I do
take all his pieces
all right here we go
I'm trying to find like a continuation
that doesn't save my pieces hanging
I can't seem to find
one
and honestly I got you haha like all
right okay okay I use elixir oh yeah
this looks rough I'll do this for now
but we'll see them I'm kind of glad that
there's no time
oh yeah it's here I didn't see it it's
okay Oh be fine
I hope all right maybe not could be a
problem
does this get him done
right now I don't know man you know what
just make moves yeah hey I forgot to
check that can you send me the link so I
can share it all no not just a stream
thing wink okay no worries
attack and see if we can get somewhere
way more way more times than I have but
you I see that you're more successful
I'm sorry I just made the five cents to
the club by watching this with guys look
I was just trying to locate the stream
to to trace you not tell her what are
you doing the job you can't watch your
videos is there a chat somewhere no okay
yeah it is but if you look at like the
whole material I'm a little bit how
would you say behind
so let's yeah
yeah I I see it and they gain so much
space I could try oh there
nevermind you keep you keep yeah I
didn't want to take with the road
because of Bishop yeah yeah ah do my
best to hold this position
go back
try to find some tricks
I wonder if this person you weren't here
for for that this person was challenging
me on the YouTube shot and I'm wondering
if they there's you know like hearing my
my thoughts on the position but there
might be a delay but still I think yeah
I hope they can't figure it out
have you watched that is like a just 24
commercial that is between I think
Lawrence Trenton Peter Svidler and it's
really it's like Oh Lawrence I'm gonna
win so it's and then he ends up loosing
it oh how do I reach this point I think
I saw why did you leave I'm here too
early because of you she's here but you
can't see her Spanish why turn my
position sucks
oh this sucks but no got a deal with it
yeah
this begun expand --is-- not at all I
don't speak Turkish compensation yeah I
guess I mean I could try there is no way
that this guy is 15 on Vinton I believe
maybe they just started yeah yeah
they don't play like 1500 no but I'll do
my best to try and save this my trusty
[Music]
Nikki do you have any idea - it's a
little fan favorite Alison struggling
here do you want to sit next to me we
can we can fit I think we can that's the
challenge me on the chat and then I just
accept it without looking at it doesn't
have any time both playing relatively
fast at least maybe I could try it like
now his penis is kind of open well the
only problem that I have in my position
is that I have three pieces for a rook
and that's not very good but other than
that yeah it's great
the show here yeah I think that's good
and then maybe I can try to make my roof
over oh go away
yeah you know and also bring the roof
into play I like to say I'm not for
membership but this night is very solid
so I don't see I tried opening it with
my phone and then it made this
advertising sound I made five cents to
this famous chess club by watching the
ad yeah 5-0 so you know go ladies
new you guys so now maybe we'll have
time for one last game before you stream
and so this either one of you want to
play I thought Nikki I want Alison yeah
depends on the order trading oh I just
oh I judge a person by their X for the
night here America trying
what's wrong with the bishop taking the
pawn and then you take those
yeah but the Knights that come here
that's yeah that's something I don't
appreciate I could take I think but then
they could yeah oh wait they could take
with the Queen but maybe I can they can
also take with the night ladies I think
then yes they take with your night you
can take the night that's true I mean
it's probably like this at the moment I
need to get rid of the bishop if I want
to like maybe but ah thank you
Oh oh crap I mister hey Chet we can we
can see you now all my events okay yeah
all right so hey just weave play they
say play hand and brain oh wait sighing
I'm terrible in the hand we have a lot
of requests and I believe we'll only
have time for like maybe one take the
Lois is there you wanna this is every
one of you want to play play hand I'm
brain or do whatever know I can be the
hand yeah would you like to be behind
all right so let's take the last here
guy wants to play but that doesn't say a
time so we can't do it if it's not
alright so how about June Ikki
sit here oh and I accept that challenge
my bad
you
okay let's find that you're gonna be the
brain let's find someone that is some
legendary meaning that someone be below
1,400 we don't have any legendary people
over here that guy okay Canada
okay we are playing with black pieces no
no I have it on the CARICOM so okay so
they they play something random
come on Canada we don't have all day I'm
sorry you might be a nice country but
you have to play excuse me you're saying
su against Ray looks like we're gonna
play somebody else how about that one
okay where can I find okay we have to
abort this one because they didn't want
to play maybe they want to tell you oh
they wanted me after a defeat no no no
okay let's find someone else who is
legendary but potentially in the
legendary border maybe this guy yeah
they say film yeah I think we found him
okay okay sorry we then get to play all
of you I want to play all of you but
yeah yeah oh my god sorry I'm supposed
to be the bat ignore this guy night
let's go night okay
yeah Bishop Bishop here I I don't
remember the theory and I played it in a
tournament and it's not here
you look for farter I don't think it
makes sense if I see them come up here
and play in front of a ton of people
okay
white wine I'm in trouble I mean I'm I'm
on the expedition right now okay
yeah pawn ones good wait yeah I think
there's a trick yeah yeah I don't Casso
only cowards castle got some castle
castle oh I see his vegetables I see
different comments it's so cool to be on
this island here I here don't Castle and
then I hear Castle I'm confused
okay
so my bad I kept forgetting that we were
playing Hannah but yeah I wanna do
Bishop you know let's just do Bishop
here or there
okay I don't think I can say something
fun fun yeah when in doubt to play a six
or a six so you can do pawn again
yeah wait yeah but I don't know since
I'm the brain I don't think I can do any
more than say it's fine yeah you can do
fun again yeah
don't assess this game as if it's this
you know high-end game
I'm under hood we played this person
before yeah the Lynx
so the problem is here this you can you
can go Bishop Bishop because it's
getting it back to a diagonal where
it'll do more than an 85 and d5 is not
really an issue because now Fischer will
be really key remember what do we put
the nice from the edge right now
oh yeah no not nice I'm showing the
lights on the rim are dim we just have
to play fast okay it's not keep
forgetting you can I say played faster
and it's my I was just passing you're
gonna do pawn yeah pawn just here yeah I
can't tell you let's see the brain yeah
you heard the brain you you should tell
me
[Music]
I'm here I'm doing a survey here so I
tried to move a piece and you say
[Laughter]
[Music]
come on I am the new one from that very
latest hand and brain thing because I
tend to because I want to help as much
as I can
yeah that that's what I like
take fine
[Music]
boom next question which bomb
[Laughter]
yeah yeah I see you'll probably have to
if they do it that's the thing that
loses upon I guess I believe so yeah I
can't have everything
sometimes you gotta you lose upon their
pieces that are doing a lot like I mean
that in the back but you know it's still
a pair of Bishops okay so they're taking
some okay open and then we have a safe
space now all right
and then maybe rerouting is somewhere
you are a lot I mean we are setting here
yeah whatever it's just the game you can
you could only say the piece name okay
yeah Bishop
but that's how you play no no that's how
you play
I have tried Henan brain blindfolded it
was quite something night it was no not
that nice how you keep scaring me like
that but I thought my job I tried Henan
brain blindfolded before it was very
interesting the trick we found is to say
night a bunch of times you can play
Knight f6 Knight e4 Knight takes of two
and it's very unlikely that they will do
King so you just keep doing 9 but
sometimes that fails so but that's a
trick I don't know maybe there are more
but that's the one we found okay so I
have to play fast pawn wow yeah so just
wait first they see me rollin I can do
night yeah the night night I just have
to be quick
yeah and try to put yeah and then pawn
and then try to put pressure on Queen
yep
or to b7 was also fun
yeah yeah yeah whatever just uh and if
95 Queen first dust Queen Queen queen
wherever whatever if I think I'll just
go to five and then take them be to
actually now if they take with night on
these six I move there but otherwise
Reba no no I don't think so but you know
they have a bunch of they hate no it's
okay I don't perform well under good
time pressure
it's okay something happened that
there's some time to to learn and
understand but it's not Gigi it's okay
Gigi's yeah whatever that was are we
allowed to play another game all right
this is it yeah yeah this week for today
I hope you guys enjoy yeah our stream I
hope you enjoyed my life something I
hope you enjoyed my queen Phoenix the I
don't talk for this much but in or 6:30
ah yes so we have yes so you know 6:30
it's the class with dorsa direction here
at the Chess Club International Master
and right after that one 7:30 and she
has another class so you can come join
it or watch it on YouTube which that's
why I like YouTube I really remember the
comments
don't worry yeah the comments are okay
alright we'll have to get ready I'll
teach that class GTA growing opponent Li
Jie Jie's if you like the stream do with
the thumbs up it helps all right I watch
the ads I'm not very entertaining but I
hope you enjoyed all right bye
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you